never before has a former U.S president
been criminally charged for attempting
to hold on to power after losing an
election Donald Trump has again made
history today an indictment was unsealed
charging Donald J Trump with conspiring
to defraud the United States
conspiring to disenfranchised voters
and conspiring and attempting to
obstruct an official proceeding
2020 81 million Americans voted voted
for Joe Biden but Trump deliberately
ignored the truth that his loss was fair
despite being informed otherwise by
credible advisors many times as
documented in the indictment instead
Trump continually repeated what
prosecutors called prolific lies that
the election had been stolen we will
never give up we will never concede it
doesn't happen you don't concede when
there's theft involved
the indictment lists six unnamed
co-conspirators that likely include Rudy
Giuliani accusing them of helping Trump
to pressure state election officials the
justice department and then vice
president Mike Pence to fraudulently
toss out votes for Biden when they all
refused according to the indictment
Trump directed his supporters to stop
Congress from certifying Biden's win
that turned into a violent attack on the
U.S Capitol leading to five deaths
it was fueled by lies
Lies by the defendant targeted at
obstructing a Bedrock function of the
U.S government
the nation's process of collecting
counting and certifying the results of
the presidential election
online statement Trump accused
prosecutors of acting on behalf of Biden
to interfere with the upcoming
presidential election in which Trump and
Biden could face off again the two are
currently tied in polls the White House
has declined to comment
Trump has been summoned to appear before
the Magistrate Judge here in D.C on
Thursday and all eyes will once again be
on the former U.S president forced to
answer to yet more criminal charges but
most notably in this case facing
accusations that he tried to overturn
the legitimate results of a democratic
election
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
Claire finkelsten she is the director of
the center for ethics and the rule of
law at the University of Pennsylvania
she joins us now from New Hampshire
thank you very much for being on Al
Jazeera first of all from what you've
been able to see so far how strong is
this case against Donald Trump
strong case because
it charges him with conspiracy along
with six unindicted
co-conspirators whose actions have been
well documented it's though the justice
department does not typically name
unindicted co-conspirators it's fairly
clear who the individuals are and
reporting that has taken place for many
many months uh has made clear what their
contribution has been for example John
Eastman who was the lawyer who crafted
the original blueprint that launched the
January 6th uh Insurrection and
convinced help to convince Donald Trump
uh that he could indeed Prevail in the
2020 election despite the clear and
resounding uh failure at the polls uh
and so the complicity of these lawyers
and five of the six are clearly lawyers
um is absolutely
um apparent has been apparent for some
time and the fact that they lent their
services to Donald Trump to both uh
convince him and to collude with him to
steal the 2020 election
um uh and to overturn the will of the
voters
um will be very convincing to a federal
jury as we heard just before the special
counsel Jack Smith described Trump's
actions as an attack on Democracy I mean
how important is this case for American
democracy and the rule of law in the U.S
in my opinion August 1st 2023 will be
remembered by this indictment as one of
the most important moments for restoring
the rule of law practically since the
end of the Civil War in this country
bringing an indictment against a former
president
who has convinced about a quarter of the
U.S population that he actually won an
election that he lost is critical not
just because it contributes to setting
uh setting the tables right with regard
to the actual law but also because it
helps to rectify the massive
disinformation campaign that Donald
Trump and his allies have been on ever
since uh the 2020 election which he lost
and so the clarity for example that Jack
Smith spoke with today in his statement
was designed not just to make a legal
appeal but to make an appeal to the
country and to its morals and to its
Democratic foundations so that we
understand how Democratic elections take
place in this country and that no one is
under any Illusions about in fact how
our elections work how much urgency do
you think there is from the doj to try
and get this case to trial as quickly as
possible you know obviously before the
elections November next year
well here's the Specter that looms over
a soul if Donald Trump were to be
elected president
and there were to be an ongoing trial at
that point and so no conviction were yet
to have come in the country would be in
a constitutional crisis of unparalleled
proportions because at that point we
have
a background principle from the
Department of Justice based on three
memos that have really been adhered to
quite strongly over time that a sitting
president cannot be indicted
now this would be a very different
situation this would be a situation in
which an individual who was previously
indicted
could potentially become president
and what would the principal then be but
were Donald Trump to become president
with uh trials still hanging over his
head he could immediately eviscerate
these trials he could replace the
Attorney General he could replace Jack
Smith he would indeed and he could start
attacking his enemies and using the
Department of Justice not to restore the
rule of law but of course to punish
anyone who had tried to hold him
accountable for his crimes so we would
be in a very bad position indeed if
these convictions had uh did not come in
prior to the election however we must
remember of course I'm talking about
convictions that any criminal defendant
Donald Trump included is Presumed
Innocent okay
thank you so much that is Claire
Finkelstein director of the center for
ethics and the rule of law at the
University of Pennsylvania thank you
thank you